if you want to be productive as an
entrepreneur then you need to make sure
you're freeing up your time to focus on
the highest priority tasks otherwise
you're going to be constantly dragged
down and sucked into the day-to-day crap
that's involved in running the business
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hunger entrepreneurs deserve help and
today i'm answering an email from a
question i mention a question from an
email that came in from one of my
readers shahed who wrote a long email
here basically summing it up he has a
cleaning business he's watched a lot of
videos and channels he subscribed to
mine he thanks me a lot thank you for
subscribing anybody watching you can
subscribe too i love seeing that
right now he's losing focus he says he
gets distracted he's by minor
disturbances it takes a lot of time to
get back into gear
uh he's living off of energy boosters
barely gets to the gym
and he's not living a healthy lifestyle
wants to be able to get more stuff done
and wanted my advice
so thanks for the questions i had hey
you know what welcome to the club this
is the life as an entrepreneur right
we're all doing way too much
we're working crazy hours
and the reality is you shouldn't be
doing 80 percent of the things that you
are doing
the way to overcome it
is one eliminate
there's probably things in your business
that you don't need to do and nobody
else should be doing
take it away a quick example
i used to host meetings or i still do
their mastermind meetings we meet once a
month i used to write minutes of what
everybody talked about
and sent off the notes to everybody one
month i forgot you know what happened
nobody cared
at first i felt a little sad you know i
spent all this time every month making
these notes sending them people think
i'm offering a value-added service
and nobody cared
so i stopped doing it and we all have
those things in our businesses i still
look for them now today in mind
things that you're doing that you should
just not do they are not adding enough
value to your business you need to
eliminate them
second you need to automate
find software tools systems that you can
use
to
get a lot of things off your plate if
i'm doing something repetitively if i do
it two or three times i find a way to
make it automatic
i'll have my programmer create a tool or
i'll find something off the shelf i use
a web tool some software whatever i can
find to automate things
because computers don't take
vacations they don't call in sick and
they take a lot of the crap off of your
plate and off of your team
and the third is delegate
you need
to get rid of the rest of those tasks
give them off to somebody who can do it
maybe even better than you but basically
you're trying to free up your time to
focus on the high priority projects if
you're stuck doing all the crap all the
time on your business you're never going
to get anywhere you're going to you're
going to level off here you're never
going to be able to get
way higher
because your time is spent doing the
tasks that you should not be doing you
need to build a team
you need to offload those tasks
that have to get done in the business
that can't be eliminated that can't be
automated through software or other
tools that still need some personal
connection to do it but it doesn't have
to be you and the last bit of device i
have is chunk your time
this has been so helpful for me
where anything that you do multiple
times a day do once a day
if you're checking your email 20 times a
day do it once a day anything you do
multiple times a week is once a week
multiple times a month once a month and
so on
it gets you in the zone i find that when
i'm switching gears
you know if i'm working on something and
somebody calls me
i help you know whatever answer the
question is then i get back to work i've
lost what i was doing you know takes me
20 30 minutes to get back into the flow
of what i was doing so i don't list my
phone number anymore
nobody calls me nobody knows my number
it's not on my website it's not on my
business card i don't even know the
number to my cell phone i needed it once
and i had to write to my dad to say
what's my cell phone number
phone calls incoming unscheduled phone
calls are other people's agenda for your
time you need to protect your time it's
the most important thing you have in
your business
i'll chunk things up in the days
so for example i'm doing these videos
i'm answering your question i love doing
videos i always do videos on a wednesday
i block off the afternoon to do videos
on a wednesday
i love it it's one of the best times i
have in the day but it takes setup time
you know i gotta set up the cameras
microphone but more i have to get in the
zone
i have to think about helping people
you know the first video is not always
the best it takes me a while to get into
it it takes me a while to get out of it
so it's better to chunk it all together
if i said i'm going to do one video a
day it would take me a lot longer to do
each day because there's so much setup
physically with equipment more mentally
where if i do one after another after
another for another it's easier to get
in that flow
i'll do my meetings on thursdays
anything where i'm interacting with
people it's on thursdays my radio shows
on thursdays my webinars are on
thursdays my mastermind meetings are on
thursdays if i have phone calls or
meetings they're on thursdays
that's my meeting day that's my talk to
the people get stuff done day
because i found
when i'm getting ready for a phone call
or a meeting
the first you know half an hour into it
before the meeting nothing gets done
if i know i'm going to meet somebody in
half an hour 20 minutes
it's hard to get into a project
right you fiddle around you do little
things but nothing major
because you know it has to end in 20 30
minutes
so i put the meetings back to back to
back to back to back and thursday is
full of meetings
and phone calls and the webinars and all
that stuff so i'm not wasting my time
then the very next day fridays i'll do
my worksheets it's my writing day i want
to come to the office you should go to
starbucks
and i'll sit down and i'll write the
whole day i don't take any phone calls
they don't answer email i just sit and
write
because when i'm writing i need to get
into zone two
and i don't want to get distracted
one email one phone call can set me off
and then i forget where i was and i've
lost my train of focus
so chunk up your day and be ferocious
about guarding your time don't let
people
waste your time
force them onto your schedule
and lastly you need to build up ceo time
you need to have a part of your day
every day that you spend on things that
are growing your business
not the tasks that you do in your
business growth new opportunities new
projects hiring people raising capital
whatever it is new things that are going
to grow your business you need to make
sure you have that time that has to be
built in and you have to safeguard it
and protect it
because if you don't have new
opportunities coming into your business
you're always going to be stuck where
you are
you're never going to be able to grow
and get to that next step i'll work on a
new project build it up to a certain
point decide if i'm going to keep it or
lose it
if i'm keeping it i give it to somebody
to manage and i'm on to my next project
if i lose it i lose it try something new
you have to make sure you have your ceo
time a lot of information in one video
it got me riled up but a very important
topic because most entrepreneurs suck at
time management and people chew their
time and you can't afford to have your
time wasted
at least i can't
you shouldn't either
don't accept people walking all over you
you have to set up the barriers
thank you guys for watching you like
this video please give it a thumbs up
below and i want to hear from you please
leave a comment with your thoughts under
this video or if you have a question for
your own business i'd love to hear it in
the comments i always read those i
really do appreciate them and i love
seeing them come in so thank you guys
and i'll see you soon